we've talked about a lot of important
issues tonight but we haven't talked
about the biggest news story of the week
the war on ukraine so we're gonna do
that right now we have a reporter
joining us live via satellite to give us
all the info this is the ukraine report
thank you amber this war has shocked the
entire continent of europe we've only
seen acts of aggression like this in
parts of the middle east and parts of
africa but never a civilized
oh what i mean is um derrick tara get
over here it's happening what a reporter
is trying to talk about ukraine without
showing his true colors
oh oh no no can i get it can i get it
over
ukraine is under attack the world is
shocked because ukraine is a european
nation a civilized nation that dang it
look i didn't mean civilized i mean like
we're all civilized if you think about
it i just mean like they all live in
buildings instead of
is
is he gonna say hut oh my god i think
he's gonna say
nope can i get another do-over
[Music]
shake it off okay
russia has attacked ukraine and this
really hits home you see the footage and
it's horrible whole families are being
ripped apart it's affecting children
blonde haired blue eyed children
damn
what
so
how did you feel when it was brown
skinned brown eyed children
do over
ukraine is suffering and we are
heartbroken
this is worse than that one time in some
african country where
i do not like this war i have never
liked a war except necessary ones like
the civil war
you know a lot of people think the civil
war is about slavery it wasn't
war
huh good god y'all what is it good
i'm not even really being racist if you
think about it cause there's all those
reports about people of color being kept
in ukraine so i'm actually reporting
about everyone including colored people
i mean
including
i don't mean to be doing this it's not
about other people this is just supposed
to be about ukraine then why don't you
actually talk about ukraine without
bringing up other people
you're right i'm sorry
[Music]
the war in ukraine is growing worse by
the day and right now we should all be
focusing on the people who are affected
the unfair suffering they're enduring
and how we should support them we wish
those affected by putin's tactics safety
and peace
thank you
[Music]
wakanda forever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you